hello welcome to another one by dr.
Sandra chalkin tots this one has to do
the question was asked to me by one
clinic students who is using you to cast
about things we thought about going to
class but which we sometimes don't get
enough time to really explore death and
it's very interesting question and it
has to do with the connection between
two different concepts and so guess is
staring at me always ac generalizations
and this comes up when we're talking
about inductive arguments inductive
arguments are arguments that at best our
probable they are not presented as one
hundred percent certain they they do
have been of exceptions and in a good
inductive Article II strong inductive
argument the premises being true provide
good reason or strong sense of credence
in truth the conclusion it doesn't make
the conclusion necessarily true it
doesn't make it possible
false two ways of saying some thing now
oftentimes understand there's anything
we are carrying out some sort of
inductive reasoning about groups of
people based on some of the members of
that group this is why we bring out in
terms of hasty generalization hasty
generalization is a common for a house
or a bad way of reasoning a bad way of
argument that tends to produce week
inductive arguments inductive arguments
privacy is being truth does not entail
that the conclusion is likely to be true
does not make the conclusion product of
life plausible so what is the fallacy of
hasty generalization sometimes as useful
they have charts and this is the chart
how we use with my students we're
talking about numerous and abductions or
another way of thinking this is how do
you generalize about a group or about a
given population given set of people or
things how do you generalize about those
by sampling a representative hopefully
representative portion so there are a
few technical terms that I
here they're not the same in every
single [ __ ] textbook but I think you
can get that the group itself the entire
group is what we call the time and why
we call it the target way I see why
we're actually might say aiming the
argument again that it's going to be
part of the conclusion of the re the
sample is what we ask you sir what we
actually take a look at and that's
pretty severely group and the sample has
some given quality and we want to say
that if the sample has this quality that
is likely or it's probable that the
group also similarly shares and equality
so for example you go out to the marsh
and you are looking around at all frogs
not only because can you actually find
all the frogs and they give it a girl
and probably not but what you do find is
100 of them and you find that
ninety-eight percent of them kind of
given parasite a new parasite that is
made that's your single event your
quality so you said 500 frogs out of
baby what's estimated five thousand
right 104 ninety-eight percent of
Hannah's parasite in them I'm willing to
bet inferring and making a reasonable
assumption they out the larger the
results of the shadows fall so that's
not that bigger problem
good sale I mean it's not a hundred
percent guarantee opinion polls that's
why they have a margin here larger the
sample gates in relation to the target
the batter and the inference if you
still have a margin of error even even
if you have a fairly large sample when
the sample is too small or when the
sample is not representative then
problem so I'm going to give you two
examples of this
let's say we'll use a small sample to
let's say you only met three people from
Wisconsin and all of them were having
beer drinkers and they can come to the
conclusion well you know Wisconsin eyes
are a lot of cause then way to solve a
simple to generalize a lot of entire
estate people it might be fun might also
get one representing let's say that you
actually met these three miss Vance
nights at the bar well now you got a
bigger problem the sample is not with
you smalls also representative because
presumably you're going to meet people
were more interested yet and have a
habit of drinking considerably the ones
who are visiting the bar if you want to
the zoo perhaps in London 23 Wisconsin
people anyone drunk then you know maybe
it's a better standing still too small
example now this is how scary to take
you off informed so this is where ebbing
is the stereotypic itself and one of the
things i want to mind you know this
stereotype it can be done any group of
people who share some from trade it
can't racial or ethnic that's what we
often think of when we think of
stereotypes could be in terms of gender
stereotype about the entire female sex
the entire male sex you can talk in
terms of particular groups within those
earlier also family man you know you
could talk about people from a given
time time ago from a certain age group
you know younger people are lazy and
irresponsible these kids these days
that's probably bad spirited you can
talk about social class people very
often do sir classes that's been going
on that's the beginning of time you can
stereotype about just about anything
else that you like things that people
enjoy you know stereotype about those
who read comic books you stereotype
about those who are into soccer you can
stereotype about how for example they
stood into directing and I remember
visiting friend of mine of France and he
said you know it's really kind of tough
for us here in France because here we
look at the real real weirdos it's not
like it is in America or
or Germany where lately it seems more
comment about those who were I don't
know if this case France back that if
you went to the gym that's a lot of time
there their way to reconsider a little
bit weird well that'd be something
exteriors head as well I'm with
stereotype about athletes we stereotype
about weekend a stereotype about all
sorts of groups and what makes us stereo
well we have some sort of given concept
with a set of traits and we use that to
make sense out of people that fall into
that class so you see somebody with a
soccer ball haha know about that first
we also do this with religion to see
somebody for instance an appeal you know
across themselves they're very Catholic
do it the other way rhythms it's
interesting because you don't realize
that you wouldn't in fact have good
reason not welcoming money back up a
little bit these days if you see
somebody in the United States especially
at my age or younger crossing themselves
and meal unless you may actually know
something about
you probably don't know that are the
same difference it probably signifies
not only are they it probably signifies
also that they're a particularly
observant or traditional because many
people in my generation and the younger
generations let it slide now how do I
know that I don't know that the basis of
looking at a few people and coming to a
conclusion I know if I haven't because I
you know religious studies and I keep up
on these sorts of things these are the
kind of indices elekta to look we do
research about this we don't just rely
on every anecdotal information that's
how you get stereotypes right now how
are stereotypes generated very often
stereotypes are generated through the
fallacy hasty generalization you mean
three hydrogen people and now you know
all cash you mean three black people
everything about african-americans you
know everything about african-americans
but advocates everything right that's
crazy isn't there are so many
differences within groups that quite
often stereotypes fail to capture or to
accurately predict what sort of Tracy
person's going to him you actually have
to look a little bit more closely we
have stereotypes not only about how a
person's gonna hate what they're going
to think as soon as you find out that
somebody belongs to
you don't feel comfortable with you may
have a tendency to ascribe without any
certain kind of fanaticism a belief in
something you're rational and it may
turn out that that person is actually
the midst of a huge struggle with their
faith they're not sure what they believe
it all and they're just going through
the motions because they don't want to
leave their religious community very
often stereotypes can't steer us into
quite mistaken conceptions of people and
again one source of stereotypes is HD
generalization you do this by countering
people in real life or perhaps just drew
through television or movies get an idea
buzzer people again to be a could be
about people who play violin it could be
about smokers some stereotypes are
actually quite positive imagine all of
them because where I want to go out of
this this is where we get to answer this
question the stereotype the
stereotypical hasty generalization the
answer is done stereotyping quite often
involves a hasty generalization made by
somebody some of our online but does it
always involved in dr. reason this is
what I this is what I think about most
of this room because of my experience
inductive reasoning is quite often
experiential know the answer is wired
sometimes there's also all teed-up
degrees in deductive reasoning if the
premises are actually true include
casting the true because deductive
reasoning works by looking at while
these grooves is going to look at the
inclusion of groups within each other so
let's say for example let's take a
concert by rich Irish people are drunk
and violent well if you begin from
definitions you know let's see you've
got those community generalizations if
you begin from definitions like all
Irish people are drunken violence that's
a group of Irish people over there there
are going to be drunk and violent as
your conclusion include forthright men
are you awake not provoke them you're
needing and deductive reasoning and if
those premises actually were true that
conclusion we have to be true the
problem is that you're working from bad
information is the classic problem of
garbage in garbage out deductive
reasoning is unassailable when the
premises are actually true if the
deductive reasoning of course is about
her there are ways of second octave
arguments where they can come about for
example all Irish people love potatoes
let's make up something really crazy all
terrorists love potatoes therefore all
Irishmen wanted terrorists about working
with false premises but even if those
premises are true the conclusion
wouldn't fall but because there's
something wrong with a form of the nice
thing about to eat at the barbican so
you can look right at them let's see
that there's something before I haven't
something so concerned that right now
what I'm really interested in is the
fact that we do engage in deductive
reasoning based on stereotypes so it so
it is is Eastern Orthodox the eastern
orthodox all love John Demasi therefore
so and so is going to love John damask I
don't know that he may not even know
anything about that particular field the
problem comes in in assuming that one he
has almost exhausted tude or these
adequate knowledge of the entire class
of people that allows one to engage in
this inferential process deductive
reasoning French people eat frogs and
snails frogs with snail are vermin
therefore French people are terminators
well again we'd have to sort of course
it's now all French people eat frogs and
snails thanks from approximants nails
really firm by most definitions you see
the problem here stereotyping quite
often begins not from
generalization but from just beginning
from the soon starting points that one
may have gotten from one's environment
from one's family from on social class
from one's group interestingly our
stereotypes quad come from more
individual process of looking at our
experience and that you know coming too
bad inferences about this but quite
often from the very fact that we belong
to Bruce we're inclined to believe what
it is that our group has to say not only
by itself what about the roofs and
forgive that were engaging and we're
just going sort of the can identify in
French like we're engaging in deductive
reasoning so there's a good case where
experience that not only is not a
multi-stage metallization it doesn't
involve inductive reasoning there's also
type of reasoning call me a doctor and
this is now I created in critical
thinking exports and sometimes not even
treated logic tentacles but it is an
important type of reasoning and in a
productive reasoning it's a little bit
more loosey-goosey sometimes it's called
inference to the best explanation a lot
of different terms for it what you're
doing is you're saying I'm observing
something here now that would explain
what would provide me with an
intelligible understanding how this is
the way it's usually something possible
now think about this in terms of human
behavior so and so does does this
someone so engages in this Bay
it's kind of possible to me is there any
sort of general rule that would explain
them because if there was that's
probably true that would then make sense
out of my experience that's a little bit
different than induction with the
adoption you're trying to sort of
accumulating cases and that's why AC
generalizations that you know induction
because the goal is to few just you know
small amount doesn't pile them up I mean
if you actually go to a given population
let's say you want to generalize about
games and you go to you know some big
game convention you actually observing
all thousand gamers you're probably
doing pretty good inductive reasoning
after the prison is different when
you're doing there is you had a case and
you're trying to think of a case
experience you're trying to make sense
so in some of the acts in this way well
why is that because they belong to this
roof and if they belong to this room
those kind of people act this way that
explains them up that could be serious
that could be how you know stereotypes
that have either come to you from your
group or from your own experience and
sufficient experience and that might be
one way would you categorize people too
quickly great examples which is a little
bit dated men was all of the family and
Archie Bunker that
here he was constantly engaging the
abductor reasoning about the motives of
people and it was almost always based on
stereotypes he's were made a classic
case in point we could think of other
ones so to recap and to summarize his
charity always needs to generalization
no it's not always hasty generalization
as a matter of fact it's not always a
matter of induction sometimes it's a
matter of deductive reasoning or
abductor reasoning and in real life
stereotypes that are floating around out
there often these things mesh with each
other reinforce each other so that
previous deductive reasoning gets used
to you know make it a deductive lead or
hypothesis or previous HD generalization
becomes the data which then gets fed
into the deductive reasoning and this is
how stereotypes not only formed but
continued through social systems in the
perpetual